it's great to have you guys on get your
paper and Pen ready I'd probably say
we've put
400 hours of research into into today's
webinar
um you're going to want to get the
webinar today we'll give it we'll give
access to people that stick around till
the very end there's going to be a bunch
of different things you'll get we're
going to cover a lot of different
families
um I've called multiple State planners
some that I'm dealing with myself
some estate planners that deal with
billionaires where they have you know 31
families of 13 billion dollars in net
worth that we're dealing with my own
setup and uh I just can't wait to share
this with you I know we've been getting
a lot of commentary on people that want
to learn about this at a time like this
so let's get right into it look if you
follow by famous content I know a few
different things about you number one
you work very hard for your money number
two you're an entrepreneur number three
you're an entrepreneur number four you
want to constantly figure out ways to
improve and when we see the economy
today with the direction inflation is
going or the market being as volatile as
it is you got to figure out a way to
protect yourself because the value
dollar keeps going lower and that
doesn't sit well with me a long time ago
I decided to invest into gold and
precious metals this is real kilo of
gold I'm holding three kilos of it right
here in my hands one of the ways to go
about protecting yourself against what's
happening with the market and inflation
is to buy silver or gold and I'm happy
to announce that we have decided to
partner with goldco so give goldco call
today to learn more about protecting
your savings and as a valutainer viewer
you could get up to ten thousand dollars
in free silver yes that's ten thousand
dollars in free silver when it comes
down to buying precious metals
reputation matters that's why I've
partnered with goldco called them today
at
855-598-2758 or click the link below to
learn more about goldcoat.com once again
that's
855-598-2758 okay so a few things number
one how to get the most out of today's
webinar number one uh close out all your
tabs that you have take notes engage in
the chat you're gonna see a lot of
commentary in this one here uh this is a
quote and you'll see why we're gonna
talk about Vanderbilts a lot in today's
webinar he once said any fool can make a
fortune it takes a man of brains to hold
on to it we'll see if he was able to
maintain to a lot of his fortune in his
family but again turn off your computers
I mean turn off your tabs set your
phones aside this could be be one of
those types of messages
that can get you to think about your
family Legacy in a completely different
way I remember years ago when I sat
there and I said what kind of a life Do
you want to build Pat when it comes down
to generational wealth I was dating a
girl and I was asking myself would you
let your daughter marry you
I was 23 or 24 years old at the Thomas I
wouldn't let your daughter marry a guy
like you today we got to get our act
together and then I started thinking
about you know trying to adjust to the
American culture where you know kids do
sleepover and all this other stuff I
said later on in life when they want to
do sleepover are you comfortable with
kids sleeping over other people's house
are you comfortable later on when your
grandfather with your grandkids wanted
to go to your kids in-laws house instead
of your house what are you going to do
for them to come to you one day what
kind of kids do you want to raise what
kind of a family Do you want to build
these are thoughts that I had very very
early on uh when I was coming up to see
what was important me it wasn't what
wasn't important to me and I'm sure many
of you that are on this webinar you
probably thought about those things as
well I'm probably not alone on that
subject so why this topic few different
things why now uh number one how I make
content I make content based on whatever
I'm learning today or going through
today so so if I'm doing a video on how
to raise money I'm raising money or I
just raise tens of millions of dollars
if I'm going through selling a company
or hiring or firing or Investments or
anything that I'm teaching you is
because I just went through or I'm
currently learning because it's a topic
that I think about a lot so how it's
evolved so why generational wealth uh I
was talking to my kids the other day and
it was a very interesting conversation
this is about a month ago a month and a
half ago because this has been the
content that I've been thinking about a
lot we were sitting there and I said hey
Tico Dylan I got a question for you they
said what I said what happens to uh
daddy's money if he dies
and uh tikon Dylan they both said well
Daddy the money goes to Mommy I said
okay you're smart so I didn't say mommy
and daddy so what happens if Mommy and
Daddy is die and what should happen with
the money
and my oldest said well the money should
go to me I'm the oldest
and you see my uh youngest son he's like
well that's not fair how about me I
should get some of the money
so then Tico and Dylan they say well
Daddy I think half of us should go to
Tico half of us should go to me
and my oldest says I think that's fair
50 50. then my daughter is eavesdropping
in the conversation she says well how
about me
I should get some of the money and you
see the broad so interesting while
they're going through it you see uh the
brother say well Senna we would take
care of you she says that's not fair do
I get any money myself and she's like
well I think we should probably give
some money to her then I say I said how
about Brooklyn the fourth baby she's 17
months well Daddy she's too young right
now so what if she's not young later on
well we'll take care of it should she
get some of the money I think she should
and then eventually I said well what if
one of you guys decides to do bad things
in your life you go to jail you do drugs
you do alcohol and you over you're not
responsible with money you're making a
mess with your life you're not me
setting a good example and you see all
of them say I don't think that kid
should get anything and I said
interesting that you guys are saying it
now because that's what's in the trust
where you have to make certain decisions
the proper way or else you're not going
to be participating any of that stuff
and the reason why I'm saying this is
because if you do the generation of what
the right way not only can you keep your
family closer if you don't do it the
right way there's so much infighting
that they don't want to be around each
other you're going to see some of the
families those that did it right and
kept the families together and those
that didn't do it right so some of the
things that will get we'll be covering
today is
a few different things we're going to
talk about six components of
generational wealth and how these guys
did it the generational wealth cycle how
generational wealth is made how
generational wealth is lost five
generational wealth Killers 14 wealth
creating habits and 11 rules of
investing so get your papers and pens
out we're going to go through this and
we're going to spend probably another
hour or about an hour and 15 minutes
together so let's get right into it
who are we going to learn from this is
the Medici family if you haven't heard
about the Medici family there's a lot to
learn from this family and then we're
going to learn from the carnegies we'll
learn from the Vanderbilt family we will
learn from the Ford family and it will
also cover a little bit of Rothschild
dynasty obviously Rockefellers and uh
those will be the families that will
focus on here today so who's on the
webinar today three types of people
those who want to learn how to create
generational wealth that may be you
those have a little bit of wealth and
want to get more and some of you that
are already wealthy and you want to
learn how to preserve the wealth that
you currently have so either if you're
one two or three we're going to cover
all three here together so Andrew
Carnegie
said with access to books or educational
content like this back then they didn't
have courses but I'm sure if they did he
would have said courses as well and the
desire to learn could educate him or
herself and be as successful as he had
been one more time anyone with access to
books and the desire to learn like
yourself that you're on right now could
educate him or herself and be as
successful as he had been so here's
what's taking place right now a few
different things Amazon is the first
company ever to lose a trillion dollar
in value that happened this year uh we
got FTX files bankruptcy bankman free
steps down we know the story about this
you're seeing it everywhere they're
talking about this who's tied to who's
not celebrities those who endorse them
it's a messy situation how Insight was a
part of it BlackRock Sequoia so many big
names a 32 billion Auto Company got two
billion dollars out of 32 billion
evaluation boom like this it's it's gone
okay Meadow leaves off more than 11 000
employees and the layoffs keep coming
left and right homeowners have lost a
trillion and a half dollars in equity
since May as housing market continues to
decline
and I can give you 50 other things on
what's going on I can talk gas prices I
can talk the direction they're
predicting you know uh uh unemployment
to go on next year interest rate
inflation there's so many things we can
talk about but if you consume the
content you've already seen a lot of
that so the six components to generating
creating generational wealth
number one mindset number two timing
number three habits number four
compounding five strategy six
relationships so let's go through a
mindset
creating generational wealth you have to
have the right mindset if you don't have
the right mindsets not going to happen
and that's not going to happen overnight
so how do you get the right mindset by
being on the right webinars the right
courses the right books you're
constantly trying to see how those who
created a ton of generational well think
and how different it is than yours I
remember years ago 21 years ago I had
one of my affirmations that said the
following you know you are where you are
because of the way you think and if
you're not happy with the with where you
are you have to change the way you think
so if you're not happy financially where
you are it's because the way you think
if you're not happy with your personal
life it's because the way you think
that's part of the mindset number two is
timing this is a very important season
right now of timing there's a lot of
uncertainty a lot of fear we just came
out of midterms elections in two years
presidential you just saw Trump coming
out he's running is it going to be the
census is it going to be Newsom your
people are worried on what's going to
happen with the economy the doubt was up
but is it real credit cards are up
people are are spending more money on
credit cards right now than ever before
what does that mean why are people
getting home equity line of credits
today and Home Depot stock is up and
Walmart stock is up does that mean
people are using their credit cards to
go spend money where they're doing okay
but at the same time the Savings in
America from q1 we had 2.3 trillion
dollars in savings we collectively were
trillionaires and that's gone from 2.3
trillion dollars to every quarter losing
300 billion dollars we're down to 1.6
trillion dollars in savings that's like
you going from twenty three thousand
dollars into banking cash to now sixteen
thousand dollars you think that's
something you'd be talking about to your
husband or your wife at night we're
saying babe just six months ago we had
twenty three thousand dollars in our
savings we're at 16. that means we can
only do this for three or four more
quarters then we're running out of
savings how are we going to handle this
in 2023 people are thinking which means
timing matters on how you react when the
market is afraid number three habits
we're going to talk a lot about some of
their habits and what they did number
four compounding which requires a lot of
patience you'll see what their strategy
of patience means to them and then some
of the strategies will cover that and
then obviously relationship the types of
people you meet the types of contacts
you make the types of people you go into
business with all of that matters a lot
that's the six components of
generational wealth so now the family
cycle we've read this before this is not
the first time you're seeing this this
isn't my quote this was said by somebody
else but we've heard it hard times
create strong men strong men create good
times good times create weak men and
weak men create hard times I saw Aaron
McKee who played for John Chaney said
John Chaney once told me to follow him
he said my grandfather walked 10 miles
to work every day my father walked five
miles I drive a Cadillac my son drives a
Mercedes most likely my grandson will be
in a Ferrari but my great grandson will
be walking again okay
so what does he mean by this when he
says my great-grandson will be walking
again it says talking but it's we'll be
walking again what does it mean that
means most people don't prepare
generational wealth and generational
habits
what needs to transfer are the habits
not just the money too often all we
think about is man I hope I get the
money passed down to my kids no you hope
the right habits gets passed down to
your kids because that's what keeps it
within the family so now the Medici
family fortune starts through a few
different things Banking and commerce
they Rose to become one of the most
important families in Florence some
estimate that they put their net worth
at 129 billion dollars adjusted for
inflation
um a few other things you need to know
about this family their family influence
lasted 500 years producing four popes
two queens of France they were the bank
for the Vatican think about it they were
the bank for the Vatican their art
patronize patronage earned them the
nickname Godfathers of the Renaissance
they sponsored Michelangelo Donatello
Leonardo da Vinci and Rafael and this is
not the ninja turtles by the way we're
talking about the legit ones not the
stuff that you and I saw as kids growing
up the book The Prince by Michael Valley
was offered to Piero de Medici okay so
you already see their resume they ruled
Tuscany from 1437 to 1737 they had the
right Network kings queens popes and
royalty they were more efficient than
others they adapted systems and
structured a bank like a corporation
they let ego be their downfall the
lineage started crumbling when the
success got to their head and they
stopped focusing on the bank so that's
the Medici now the next one is the
Carnegie family he grew up poor in
Scotland and was making 1. a dollar 20
at his first job in U.S Andrew
Carnegie's Fortune peaked at around 309
billion dollars he was the richest man
in America after selling his company in
1901 Carnegie entered the steel industry
in 1873 and started his first company
that evolved into the Carnegie Steel
company a few things about their family
Legacy at his death Carnegie donated
most of his money to build over
2509 libraries and schools like the
Carnegie Mellon University he's referred
to as the patron saint of libraries that
was a big part of his mission on what he
wanted to do with his life he left his
wife and nine children with a trust of
about 10 million dollars each and the
properties he owned
by the second generation they began
donating their land to the National Park
Service in the 1970s due to expensive
upkeep
so what can we learn from these guys he
was an early Pioneer Pioneer by bringing
in Bessemer process of making steel to
the U.S and created a fortune in the
process Carnegie grew up poor and
believed the way to wealth was through
self-education this is something that
I've applied myself you hear about the
song valuetainment and many other people
who are self-educated folks this is one
way he created his mind and his wealth
as well his legacy involved giving back
to the schools and libraries so that
people just like him could access the
resources he had that allowed him to
build his wealth you can create a legacy
by helping more than just your family so
what's the point here with Carnegie what
is your legacy what do you want to leave
behind you know you hear me talk about
capitalism all the time in books and
Business and Entrepreneurship and
Entrepreneurship what is it for you that
gets you excited about it is it
orphanage maybe that's something that is
part of your passion is it
kids is it you know women men is it
businesses what is it that you want to
leave behind that's part of your cause
and your crew say this was a big part of
Carnegie's DNA next we have the
Vanderbilts when Cornelius Vanderbilt
was 16 years old he turned a hundred
dollars into a hundred million dollars
which is 200 billion dollars adjusted
for today's money his mom gave him 100
million 100 and he turned into what it
is 200 billion dollars today it was
roughly equivalent to 50 percent of U.S
treasury at the time think about that
right there 50 of the U.S treasury at
the time this is how rich Vanderbilt was
uh during his time he created a fortune
for himself through his Ferry and
railroad companies he was known to be a
harsh man who rarely trusted his family
with his business and money with 13 kids
he only left one of his sons with the
skills to handle his money and his
business okay so think about that I
think he had eight daughters I don't
think he left the penny for anyone one
of them because he didn't didn't think
there's any benefit to leaving women or
his girls any money very interesting guy
Vanderbilt was well let's see if this
philosophy worked or not so here's his
legacy when Vanderbilt died his son
William took over his fortune and
doubled it to 200 million dollars by the
time he died in 1885 however within 50
years of cornelius's death the fortune
was completely gone so think about it in
50 years 200 billion dollars
gone there's no money Anderson Cooper's
mom said we may be part of the
Vanderbilt's family but there's no trust
fund here kid not going to give you
nothing you got to go make your own
money so whatever money Anderson
Cooper's made he's made on his own the
third and fourth generation grew up
ridiculously lavishly and spent their
fortunes like crazy that the sentence
were prone to family competition
building huge mansions to rival each
other and this is one of them by the way
when you see this Mansion you think this
is a hotel this is not a hotel this was
built as a vacation home finished in
1895 30
000 acre estate
250 room French Renaissance Castle took
six years and cost nearly six million
dollars to build which in today's money
you ready
1.6 billion dollars by today's standards
why does somebody need a 250 room French
Renaissance castle for vacation well
that's what these guys did and what
happened to that money it disappeared
builtmore builtmore house is considered
the largest privately owned home in the
entire country and is still operated by
the Vanderbilt descendants today
uh 179 000 square feet give or take with
35 bedrooms for family and guests 43
bathrooms 65 fireplaces and three
kitchens in this place okay so what can
we learn here don't bring family into
business and teaching them the trade
they didn't do that he didn't want to do
it he said I'm just going to do one of
my kids out of the 13 but I don't want
to teach the kids how I made the money
lack of wealth habits led to poor money
management and entitlement
wasted the wealth on crazy lavish
lifestyle don't be like the Vanderbilts
that's pretty much the story of
Vanderbilt if there's one family you
don't want to be like it is a Vanderbilt
okay specifically in generational word
to creating wealth be like Vanderbilts
to pass the end of wealth you do not
want to be like the Vanderbilt here's
the Rothschilds
mayor Rothschild returned to Frankfurt
in 1763 at the age of 19 joined his
brothers in the trading business started
by their father okay
mayor Rothschild return to Frank then
Rothschild banking empire grew rapidly
during the French Revolution before he
died he left strict instructions for his
heirs on how they should handle family
finances so their strict instructions
being left behind so he was Progressive
he was prepared he knew he wanted to get
these guys to think the right way in the
early 1800s Rothschild sent his sons to
live in Naples Vienna Paris and London
in addition to keeping the sun in
Frankfurt the five linked branches
became the five link branches became in
effect the first bank to transcend
borders lending to governments to
finance War operations over several
centuries provided the Rothschild family
with ample opportunity to accumulate
bonds and build additional wealth in a
range of different Industries the
family's Network peaked at around 500
billion dollars after the Napoleonic
Wars when they were financing both sides
so what can we learn from these guys
traditionally irath's child's Fortune is
invested in closely held corporations
today the Rothschild Corporation have
continued to see success most family
members are employed by these
corporations directly or are invested in
operations that generate family wealth
the remarkable success of the family has
largely been due to a strong interest in
corporations being entrepreneurs in the
practice of smart business principles
the family motto is Concordia integritas
industria which means harmony integrity
and Industry so the family had a certain
set of values and principles that they
keep teaching therefore the family still
has been able to keep the money next
this one's also an interesting one the
Ford Fortune Henry Ford's Fortune peaked
at around 200 billion dollars his wealth
was almost three percent of the U.S GDP
in 1913.
start at Ford Motor Company in 1903 and
quickly became the largest automotive
manufacturer in the world okay their
legacy upon his death Ford left most of
his vast well to Ford Foundation
arranged for his family to control the
company permanently
Fords collectively are worth around 2
billion dollars it is the fifth
generation of fourth Sons grandsons and
cousins to own the company the family
owns nearly 40 percent of voting power
in Ford company so now what can we learn
from these guys upon his death trusts
were in place in order to practice
protect most of his wealth from excess
taxes and transfer wealth by the way
this is something that most people don't
realize when it comes down to estate
planning Elvis died with nothing being
passed down to his family his kids so
did MLK so did Abraham Lincoln there are
a lot of families that were not prepared
for this and they didn't do proper State
plannings a lot of celebrities a lot of
athletes Babe Ruth up nothing pretty
much for his family just because they
didn't take the time to think about
generational wealth they were just
looking at the money in themselves in
their lifetime they didn't say well one
day I'm gonna die I'm sure that day is
going to come out be ready when that day
comes and they never get prepared most
people don't get prepared for this the
fact that you're on this webinar right
now tells me this is something that's
important to you and kudos to you to do
what most are not willing to do this
gives you an advantage of over other
people and uh obviously everything will
come down to execution but you do have
an edge the fact that you want to learn
how to do these things so they managed
to keep the business within the family
and each generation took the company and
moved it forward the transfer of wealth
was Swift and the business Acumen and
wealth habits were left intact okay so
whatever they learned he passed it down
and the kids and grandkids kept using
those skill sets to grow the company to
the next level
Rockefeller started out as an assistant
bookkeeper making 50 cents a day his
fortune peaked at around 418 billion
dollars again another three percent of
U.S GDP around the same time as a uh
Ford started Standard Oil in 1870 and
grew to control 91 of oil production and
85 percent of oil sales in the United
States okay
upon his death all the money went into
trust control by male Heirs of the
fortune that were designated designed to
maintain the wealth
there are over 150 direct descendants of
Rockefeller and their net worth is
estimated to be 8.4 billion dollars the
fifth and sixth generation are aren't
likely to be able to live off of their
Family Trust according to people close
to the family they currently hold no
money making family businesses it's
purely Investments the family members
individually donate 50 million dollars
each year and the foundation donates 170
million dollars every year generational
skipping trusts were in place which is a
beneficial thing to have in place
Rockefeller had trusts in place to make
sure that the money was event evenly
distributed so this isn't something
where one got more than the other the
approach he took he wanted to be evenly
distributed the family had developed a
system of values traditions and
institutions that have helped the family
stay together and preserve the wealth
think about that one right there what
set of values and traditions uh do you
want to pass down to your kids think
about a person sitting there to think
about that and say hey babe this is one
of what I want to pass on to my kids
here's what I want them to be doing
these are our values one of the things
we talk about a lot in our family is
lead respect improve love those are four
things we do as a family we don't bully
we don't get bullied and there's four
things we pray for courage wisdom
tolerance understanding obviously
there's a lot of other values I'm giving
you the basic of what we teach you can
tell these families think about these
things and it's repetitive and they keep
talking about it over and over and over
again I'll never forget a story Arnold
told the first time he met
when he married Maria Shriver he said
the first time I met one of the Kennedys
he said so what's your favorite color
and he said we like red
he says no no what's your favorite color
he says yeah we like the color red
he says I I don't think why are you
saying wheat what do you like he says we
the Kennedys like the color red why
would somebody say something like that
because the family talks about we like
the color red so how detailed is that to
say this is our color of what we like
something again to be thinking about not
saying go pick your favorite color and
say in our family we like to color
purple purple but the point is they're
thinking about details like this so and
the last one even Rockefeller made
mistakes when he came down to planning
uh there's a certain number that uh I
think you had a 1.4 billion dollars of a
state when he died at the time obviously
today's money is 400 billion dollars but
1.4 billion at the time 70 percent of it
got taxed just so you know only 400
million dollars ended up going to the
family
70 percent because there was no will in
place Rockefeller had no will in place a
basic will
cost you a couple hundred dollars to put
together there was no will cost the
family
seventy percent of 1.4 billion dollars
think about that just taking the time to
put together well again our job is to
learn from what people did right and
learn from what they did wrong and do
what they did right and don't do what
they did wrong so what did they have in
common few different things
number one they all chose a grown
industry and were early adopters number
two they found a problem and created a
solution three they had equity and
businesses that grew and last but not
least this is a tough one for many
people
it took them 24 to 40 years to amass
their wealth do you have that kind of
patience 20 to 40 years to amass that
kind of wealth a lot of time people talk
about well Elon Musk is worth a few
hundred billion dollars in today's money
et cetera Etc well I mean Elon Musk has
been doing this for a long time nearly
30 years
he's been doing what he's doing with
business when he's when they saw PayPal
for one and a half billion dollars his
share was 180 million dollars you know
what he did with his 180 million dollars
he put 100 million dollars into SpaceX
he put 70 in Tesla and I think he put 10
million in the Solar Company and that
180 million dollars turned into 250
billion dollars today give or take
depending on how the economy is because
he's a long-term thinker Warren Buffett
today is worth 109 billion dollars you
know how long he's been at it a long
time he's also a long-term thinker this
is very common when you look at people
who create a ton of wealth so getting
rich is different from staying Rich okay
slow money Long Money the longer it
takes it eventually takes to accumulate
the longer you hold on to it they all
spend 20 to 30 years building their
wealth fast money quick money therefore
70 percent of lottery winners end up
broke within a few years think about
this this is a study that MIT did didn't
somebody just win two billion dollars
right now at the lottery what do you
think is going to happen with this
regular person that gets two billion
dollars you think they know how to
manage two billion dollars if the
person's Never Had a Million Dollars
their identity if their job is fifty two
thousand dollars a year they get two
billion dollars what do you think you're
going to be doing with that money how
quickly think that goes away even though
you may say come on Pat you think a
person can run through 1.9 billion
dollars in no time yes absolutely
because if you don't know how to manage
it and if your identity doesn't believe
your worth 1.9 billion and you think
you're only worth twenty two thousand
dollars of savings in the bank somehow
some way either someone's gonna rob you
of that money someone's going to take
that money from you you're going to
break the law you're going to pick up
bad habits like drugs alcohol and then
boom the money disappears most of the
time according to MIT the people who get
rich quick lack something crucial to
generational wealth generational wealth
habits this is exactly what we're
talking about so number one they invest
in sure bets to something that these
guys did number two investing in
appreciating assets three structuring it
generational they think about how am I
going to get this money to go to the
kids and to grandkids it is something
they think about practicing
apprenticeship what can I do to develop
these leaders what can I do to teach my
habits to them they come to work they
see how Mommy's working they see how
that is working they see how you growing
your business whenever I'm doing a
conference call I like my kids to listen
to many of these conference calls so
they see how I'm negotiating they see
how I'm talking and then afterwards
they'll ask me question that is a form
of apprenticeship my six-year-old
daughter
I went home right now to pick up a few
of these uh kilo of gold because I was
doing a video for gold my daughter
immediately Daddy can I come back to the
office can I come back she just wants to
be here and I'm like absolutely you can
come here today she had to do homework
and she had something she had to do or
else she would have been here think
everything about duplicating good habits
to your kids most of the time kids will
only see the bad habits but think about
what good habits we can do duplicate to
the kids being pioneers and trendsetters
so some of you guys may say well Pat
what do you want me to do with oil
that's already done railroad who the
hell is going on I've never been on the
train before I'm not going to get on
train planes what can I do that's going
to be revolutionary either be
revolutionary or join a revolutionary
either be a Pioneer or jump on a Pioneer
ship playing and say I'm going with you
wherever you're going I'm going on this
rocket we're going places I'm going to
bring my value to you but either way
either be a Pioneer and trendsetter or
join a Pioneer and trendsetter changing
the business with The Changing Times
They knew how to pivot and adjust
recognizing and capitalizing
opportunities that's something you got
to be thinking about and you got to be
looking at teaching the family early not
waiting till later on to teach them the
right habits staying away from the
spotlight very interesting to say stay
away from the spotlight this is this is
interesting where this was a big part of
philosophy where they want to be a
little low-key even if you think about
the Koch brothers or Rothschild you
don't hear a lot from them you may even
not be able to say that you hear a lot
from many of these people who made their
wealth then it's very different today
it's hard for Bezos or musk or a lot of
these guys to stay away from the
spotlight today because we have
something called social media and
whether you like it or not the media is
going to somehow pull you in but do your
best to stay away from the spotlight
this is what some of these guys did
leadership and family is based on Merit
which means you gotta earn it kind of
like how I talk to my kids when I said
Hey what if one of you guys does
something bad should that person still
get the money no you should you know
okay great perfect no problem so
families have certain set of values in
place to get that wealth you talk about
that early very simple the other day I
was walking with one of my neighbors
this guy's family they have 7 000
employees classy guy we always talk I
give him value stayed up till God knows
what time for him to create content and
we are like oh my God I can't believe
how to do this how to do this you're
going to be great but while we're
walking and uh this is uh Halloween and
we're doing trick-or-treating while
we're walking his son walks by and uh so
how you doing great his son's playing
football
and he says um yeah he lost his
technology privileges for seven weeks I
said what do you mean technology
privileges he says he lost his
technology privileges what do you mean
by that well you know I phoned video
games stuff like that I said why did he
lose it he says oh in our family very
basic in our family if you don't have
straight A's you lose technology
privileges I said really he said yeah if
you don't have straight A's you lose
technology privileges think about that
so I sat there and I came back and I
said I've been thinking about a way to
talk to my kids about getting a phone
because a lot of people are having
phones uh they say oh how am I going to
get these guys the phones now there's a
system so the point is leadership in
family is based on Merit that's a merit
you want technology uh uh you want
technology you got to make sure you have
straight A's so these are some of the
things that you borrow to create in your
own family next maintaining strong
family connections keeping people
together reunions traveling together I
remember I was dealing with this one
insurance guy very very successful guy
and uh who had had a massive exit and he
had started a annuity company out of
Kansas City and one day I'm sitting down
with him talking to him I said so tell
me some of your family traditions the
guy was in his 70s so I would like to
learn a lot from people that are super
successful he says every year I take 89
of my family members
on a vacation and I pay for the whole
thing I said what really he said
absolutely two weeks I take him I said
are you joking he says no he said let me
show you some pictures he shows me this
is a cruise this is 89 of us and he
starts telling me I started doing this
20 years ago first one we did was only
11 of us then it went to 15 then it went
to 20. imagine the pictures he's shown
every year he says now it's 89. all
these grandkids all these boyfriends and
girlfriends it says 89 we go together so
why do you do this he says believe it or
not it keeps the family united we're all
together I'm like wow very interesting
he told me this in 2009 when I started
the insurance company 14 13 years ago
this Christmas
I tell my wife when it comes down to one
thing that I don't hold back it's
experiences with the kids this Christmas
we're probably going to spend four to
five hundred thousand dollars on our
Christmas last year was three hundred
thousand dollars there's one thing that
I'm gonna do to bring the family
together is something like this you get
to use your resources to create the
family to come together when I was
thinking about as a 23 year old one day
I want my grandkids to choose to come to
my place I want to build an estate where
kids can get to play swim do whatever
they want and the in-laws can be in a
complete separate house so Christmas
Thanksgiving summer vacations all my
grandkids want to come to me because I
want to stay close to my kids and my
grandkids those are some of the things
you do to keep the family connections
together again so some people may say
Pat you're out of your mind that's
important to me what's important to you
this doesn't apply to everybody but
that's what I think about it what do you
think about and finding ways to maintain
strong family connections next build
strong business networks you know
connections is a very big thing today I
just get a call out of nowhere and this
guy says hey Pat uh uh uh one of our
guys here that we work with he says hey
you know there's this guy just talked to
and he just came up to me and he's been
following by attainment for a while and
he wants to be our contact for Hollywood
for Grammys for all this stuff and there
are people that want to be the agent
because they want to you know they're
seeing what's going on here where we
have a lot of exposure on social media
and the internet but we don't have it on
mainstream media and they want to talk
to you this is a connection of a
connection of a connection when you
build strong relationships you know I
remember when first time I read a book
about Bill Clinton running for office
when he was a governor in Arkansas and
he became the president beating George
Bush Senior he said he wrote 20 000
handwritten notes that he gathered on
this Rolodex forget about all the bad
things you may think about with Bill
Clinton the man was an incredible
networker he took his 20 000 contacts
that he had gathered Rolodex wrote
everybody a note
I am running for office here's a reason
I would love to get your support and
then boom all these connections helped
him eventually become a president it
doesn't matter what it is your contacts
may want to be your kids contact very
important to build strong business
Networks
being cautious of who you bring into the
fold very very uh interesting you talk
about who dates you who dates your kids
and saying and breaking it down to find
out who the family of the kid that's
dating you you know kind of being a
little bit more proactive hey hey Daddy
I love this guy great let me meet his
family
you know hey Mom I love this girl great
let's meet her family it doesn't matter
what it is you want to keep them close
to see who they're getting close to
friends hey I hang out with this guy
named Joey great bring him over for a
pool party and then you look oh Joey was
smoking weed over there at 13 years old
yeah we're gonna have a problem here we
gotta figure this thing out now I know I
talk to the family we're being proactive
you got to be proactive you have to stay
paranoid Ray dalio said something very
interesting this last week I watched a
clip of his and he said you know if you
worry you won't have to worry but if you
don't worry you will have to worry what
does that mean if you worry about the
economy you're probably not going to
take a massive hit because you'll be
overly prepared he says but if you don't
worry about economy your kids how you
raise them finances rates you know
politics if you don't worry about it
guess what you're gonna have a lot to
worry because it's all going to impact
you the whole concept is to be a little
bit cautious of who you bring into the
fold very very important the way this
applies to lawyers estate planners
accountants firms Consultants very very
careful who you bring on the inside 14
capitalizing of certain aspects of the
law they talk about loopholes but this
is the benefit of having the right
accountants overpaying for accountants
to protect you against laws that change
I've had lazy accountants before if you
got lazy accountants just because
they're a friend or family and they're
working independently they're by
themselves and you're starting to do
very well maybe it's time to fire your
account as much as you love them you got
to move on my recommendations always to
go to a top 50 accounting firm
because a top 50 accounting firm they
have responsibilities and if God forbid
one of their accountants does something
bad to you they're held responsible to
have another team come and fix it and
they typically have tax planning you
know laws changing they'll tell you I'll
talk to my account they'll say hey let
me tell you for the State of Texas this
change for Florida that change for
California this is what's going on so we
may be able to do this for this day but
not the other state so again very very
important to know what's going on with
tax laws and the loss of your industry
period so that's that now generational
wealth Killers number one lack of wealth
habits very simple if you have lack of
wealth habits sudden wealth syndrome you
all of a sudden get money you don't know
what to do with it your identity didn't
catch it didn't match your money you may
all of a sudden get 10 million dollars
but you're only used to making 60k man
you better change your identity up to
upgrade thinking like a 10 million
dollar person which means don't do
anything with the money anytime soon
until you start thinking what it is that
10 million dollars so sudden wealth
syndrome is very very problematic this
happens in sales you'll see somebody
that's making four thousand dollars a
month ten thousand dollars a month and
all of a sudden they sell a four million
dollar home and they get 150 000 check
or a hundred thousand dollar check and
they buy four Rolex as a Ferrari and a
Lambo thinking this is going to happen
forever boom six months today they lose
the Ferrari they lose the lambo they
sell their watch that bought for twenty
thousand dollars for two thousand
dollars two or five thousand dollars to
you this is called the sudden wealth
syndrome I lean towards buying things
that I can't afford today typically
you're two years later ah not yet ah not
yet not yet not yet at 250 000 in the
bank at 27 28 years old and I was
driving a Ford Focus and everybody was
saying Pat are you broke I'm like no I'm
not ready to buy an exotic kid and my
friends were like well if that's my
million dollar home let's buy this
because this was the ninja side no
income no assets no jobs I'm like I'm
not buying nothing yet eventually I'd
have had a half a million dollars I took
that Finance by insurance company and
obviously we just were able to sell the
company for a few hundred it was a very
good experience when that took place but
it's sudden wealth syndrome okay three
lack of concentrated wealth okay lack of
concentrated wealth you know it's it's
all over put a place you know you don't
have it too focused yes you want to make
sure you have a you know diversification
maybe a good thing but if you want to
create true wealth typically it's better
to have it more focused in certain
sectors and too many different places
some may disagree with me and say Pat
what are you talking about you got to
diverse about I get it totally
understand it's all about your risk
tolerance and your time Horizon but if
you want to create true true wealth you
got to be a little bit concentrated in
Industries you're looking at I went
insurance industry one industry 20 some
years I've been in it till today 21
years one industry Pat try loans nope
guys call me Pat what if we team up to
do real estate nope hey what if we team
up to nope I'm Insurance well that's a
boring industry really not so boring for
me I love this industry look what we did
to it there was a problem in the
insurance industry what was it only 17
percent of Agents were women
we build an insurance company 54 we're
women only Hispanics nobody was selling
them Insurance we're 51 Hispanic the
average agent was a 56 year old white
male our average agent became a 34 year
old Hispanic female everybody was stodgy
and you know boring when he would go to
conventions our conventions are wild a
Kevin Hart will be doing a one-hour
irresponsible tour and make 6 000 people
laugh we brought a President Bush to
talk about what happened with his life
how he became a president will bring the
lake Kobe Bryant will bring people like
Billy Bean and entertainment and hey you
know Sebastian Maniscalco come and give
a performance make everybody laugh we'll
have Shaq come up Mike Tyson come up
we'll put up a concert with Nicky Jam
we'll put a concert with Nelly but we
saw a leak in an industry that was
traditionally known as being boring we
made it exciting and we changed it up so
so that's that's something you got to be
thinking about so break down in trust
and communication no next parents not
preparing children and not talking to
them Jamie Johnson and heir to the
Johnson Johnson Healthcare Fortune says
in his documentary born rich that he was
clueless about the extent of his family
wealth until a young schoolmate read his
father's listing in the Forbes 400 out
loud to the entire class let me read
this one more time to in case you missed
it Jamie Johnson had no clue she just
thought I'm just Jamie Johnson she had
no idea she was an heir to the Johnson
Johnson family
and the documentary born rich which is a
good documentary watch that he was
clueless about the extent of his
family's wealth until a young classmate
rather's father's listing
in Forbes 400 he's like wait that's my
Dad wow my dad's a billionaire this kid
never knew his dad was a billionaire
think about how those parents raise the
kids right preparing parents not
preparing kids right
so now here's a few different things 11
P's when it comes down to investing
these are my 11ps on what I look at when
I invest into different things some of
it you can borrow some of it you may say
no it's not for me number one I invest
in people meaning operators I feel musk
is a good operator so if I had a chance
to invest into Twitter I would have
risked a few million dollars to invest
into Twitter because I trust in him as
an operator is there risk there of
course there is he's been targeted but I
like to invest in great operators okay
like there's a story on Business Insider
this one guy who was friends with Warren
Buffett I don't know what year this was
by the way Tyler if he can look it up
1950s or 60s early on maybe even 74 or
72 and this guy says look I was friends
with Warren Buffett he told me to put
ten thousand dollars in Berkshire
Hathaway I did and I never looked at it
I went back to my regular job he makes
80 grand Year by the way but he put ten
thousand dollars on Berkshire Hathaway
he said why did you so I really believed
in the person Warren of it you know how
much that ten thousand dollars worth
today you ready a billion dollars ten
thousand dollars he put never touched
the money the guy's a billionaire
because he invested in the right person
he said this guy's going places and he
was right okay so first P invest in
people second p
invest in Perpetual things I like
Perpetual things that money keeps coming
in Netflix you're paying 12.99 per month
okay different types of services where
the money is being paid on a regular
basis it's a membership model which is
Perpetual number three is phenomenons or
phenomenon uh phenomena right now I I
just bought a few massive cars I bought
a you know I bought the pat Mahomes the
second best card it's a one of one RPA
beautiful card I'm a Joe burrow fan I
bought his card I bought Pat Mahomes
card one of one as well I think it's his
second best card as well both of them
second best card I just bought mbappe's
best card if you guys know the soccer
player mbappe I own mbappe's best card
spend a couple hundred thousand dollars
on it World Cups coming up if France
wins and he's a superstar there I think
they're third right on the odds to win
that's a phenomenon that's a risk but
it's a risk I'm willing to take right
some people did Netflix uh the nfts that
was a phenomenon that a lot of people
invest some money into it phenomenons
are not something you invest a big post
your money into every once in a while
you look at phenomenals number three
number four problems ubereats solves a
problem Lyft solves a problem number
five preventative this is gold okay I
got three kilos of gold sitting here
this is purely preventative I'm not
expecting this gold to help me become a
billionaire not at all but it's
preventative I own some gold in case
something happens this is not going to
make you super wealthy but it is
preventative by the way insurance is
also preventative I want a lot of life
insurance it's preventative number six
patents someone's got a good patent
they're typically not good operators but
if there's a real good patent and a good
team behind it I'll consider it number
seven is product what product it is
sometimes you see a product we like I
just really like that product and I use
that product I want to invest into that
product great it is a product I
personally use number eight predictable
you just know it's a very predictable
ETF or EFT or mutual fund something very
predictable that people put their money
in prep property uh depending on
commercial or residential 10 Priceless
this is me and my family last Christmas
This Is Us in Whitefish Montana
had a great time we flew in on a private
jet stayed there for a week
at a 20 some thousand square foot home
right behind us do you see right behind
us is where they're skiing I don't know
if you see that now or not to the top
left right behind my nanny uh right
there people are skiing so you look out
the window you see skiers snowboarders
we had a couple of our guys I think I
think even Mario tried to go out there
and ski it was a very bad situation
we're just happy he's okay live here
with us we had a couple of our friends
Matt and Rodolfo try to ski they both
nocho couldn't stop skiing you can tell
that some people don't know how to ski
they went into a community because they
didn't know how to stop funny story but
they're all healthy nobody broke any
legs these are Priceless Memories I will
talk about forever it's an incredible
time we watched a Christmas movie can
you guess what Christmas movie we
watched Tyler I guarantee you you can't
guess what Christmas movie we watched
there is nothing about this movie that
has to do with Christmas
now you know what we watched we watched
Primal Fear who the hell watches Primal
Fear for Christmas the bed David family
we sat there in the movie theater and we
sat there and watched Primal Fear why
because I just loved the scene when you
know Edward Norton goes like this to
Richard Gere anyway these are our
memories I invest in Priceless Memories
with my family we just bought the box
seat at the Tampa Bay Bucks playing
against Cincinnati Bengals 36 people I'm
taking a bunch of friends and clients
and customers and agents we're gonna go
there and I'm taking the kids we're
gonna watch Joe Bro play Tom Brady could
probably be the last game they're going
to play against each other that's a nice
investment it's Priceless for us right
and then the last one the last P of
investing is planning
planning this is the one that's boring
to most people but this is what pays a
lot pays very well if you do planning so
the lack of planning in your life will
ruin the financial future of your
planning of your family let me explain
what's the one thing you can spend hours
and hours building day in and day out
does anybody know what I'm talking about
it's Legos okay you ever seen these
Legos I don't know if you're a Lego
person or not we like to build Legos
matter of fact this Lego right here I'm
gonna show you my kids just finished
building this last night and I told them
I'm going to bring back so they can see
it they spend so much time building this
layer I don't know if you guys can see
this or not can you see it just take a
look at it
did it break
you got to be kidding me I dropped that
thing can you see it real quick
oh my God
seriously that thing broke can you take
a look at if it broke
by the way I did that intentionally just
so you know that my kids didn't spend
time building that last night okay this
is what I built here well you know I'm
showing you this here's what happens if
you and I don't plan
this breaks
you spent time putting this thing
together
you your family
you spend time creating your wealth
you spend time working your tail off to
make money
don't you think it makes a little bit of
sense to put time and planning
hours how hard do you work if you're
watching this
how hard do you work this is obviously a
little the guys wanted me to bring the
big what do you call that big one the
biggest one that Lego has do you know
the name of it the Star Wars there's a
what's it called I don't think it's I
think it's another one the Falcon the
massive Falcon we did one with my kids
took us five hours to make but myself
Adam Mario we decided to do the biggest
piece Lego ever had you know how many
hours it took us we made a YouTube video
we try to break the German MIT graduates
record we failed miserably we're not
going to bring that to break it that
took a long time for us to build right
the same way you treat your wealth to
not break it you got to protect it comes
down to planning my kids like Legos
their daddy likes Legos they sit there
if you want to find a way to irritate my
daughter guess what have my sons come in
break her Barbie house if you want to
find a way to upset my son here he likes
to build forts with pillows and blankets
if one of the kids breaks what he built
with his four words fights breaking out
in the house Photon fights breaking on
the house why because you spent hours
building that you've spent out building
your current business now you ought to
protect it right that's the whole reason
why we're doing this
so if you spend time then someone breaks
it and you weren't prepared for it it's
your responsibility we ought to figure
out a way to prevent people from doing
that it's not going to feel good when
that happens
so now what happens to that thing that
you are spending your life building when
you pass away and you're not prepared
for it have you planned who is going to
take care of it some of you may be
watching the same pad I didn't come here
because I got generational wealth I want
to find out how to create generational
wealth well regardless if you have it or
if you don't have it generational wealth
equals planning FYI watch what happens
when you talk planning with people out
there you and I don't like that topic
because we're looking for that special
potion to take to create a ton of wealth
we don't like the topic of planning just
the ward itself is boring but this is
what these guys do this is what I've
learned to do my entire life lacked
planning until I understood the power of
planning right now I'm working uh
um
working on this book I'm writing with
penguin we're so excited about this book
it's not coming out for another year and
a half and we've been putting hours on
top of ours my whole mind is around
business planning and life planning
right now penguin bought the book we're
excited about it portfolio the whole
concept is 12 building blocks of writing
a business plan because most people
don't know how to write out a business
plan and that's what we're talking about
with this book so there's three types of
planning there's business planning
there's financial planning there's
estate planning
this session is not for financial
planning or state planning Financial
Planning and estate planning will help
you keep your wealth this whole session
was about business planning business
planning is what will help create wealth
so for those of you that want to help
create wealth that's what we're talking
about today and by the way what season
are we in this is uh we're going into
the third week of November Thanksgiving
is a week from today I believe today is
Thursday right a week from today's
Thanksgiving like this Christmas is here
like this is January 1st
2023 is here are you prepared for it
have you done a lot of planning this is
my season when I start thinking about
next year's planning for 2023 a
psychology professor in California did a
study on goal setting she found that you
are 42 percent more likely to achieve
your goals just by writing them down so
this is the season to think about how
you're going to be writing your business
plan down but here's the issue with most
business plans it feels like homework to
most people if you talk about business
plan they think they're doing homework
and it's back to school and how many of
us just love doing homework if you're
like me you probably don't like doing
homework
starts working on it end of December
it's kind of too late it's kind of like
I got to get a business plan fourth week
of December you put an hour to do it
just like as if you got something done
I'm gonna lose 20 pounds I'm gonna make
this much money I'm gonna get a
promotion boom it's rushed you stop
looking at it by the beginning of
February too logical not enough emotion
it's over that's 99 of people's business
plan that's how I wrote business plans
and I never looked at the business plan
again
until I realized what was missing in my
business plan do you think Rockefellers
treated his business and business
planning that way do you think any of
these guys did it that way Carnegie Ford
any of the ones that made the money and
kept it with their families what do you
think they did differently
they had a life plan that included the
right building blocks once I structured
my business plan with the 12 building
blocks my life completely changed okay
and by the way these building blocks
when I explained to you it's going to be
different than what you've heard before
because too often everybody links a lot
of logic to business plan and most
people don't realize that emotion is
what makes the business plan work not
the logic making a business plan work
let me explain to you too often when you
look at these building blocks on the
left side you see the word skill many of
us sit there and say oh my God I gotta
learn how to sell I gotta learn how to
negotiate I got to learn how to handle
difficult conversations that's the skill
I need yeah but how are you going to
improve your willpower
when it's Friday night you had a bad
week you didn't sell anything things
didn't go your way you know and you're
like well you know whatever I'm gonna do
it next week and you still have that
next week mentality instead of let me
get it done today your willpower is I
said I'm gonna go to the gym this
morning I'm gonna do it tomorrow every
time you say tomorrow your willpower
gets weaker every time you do it now
your willpower gets stronger so yes you
want to figure out a way to improve your
skill set but how are you going to
improve your willpower you tell me
anybody who won at the highest level
you'll see somebody that has strong
willpower in sports they'll use the
phrase they will themselves into winning
the Super Bowl hence
Patriots against Atlanta Falcons when
they were down 28-3 it wasn't just skill
that got him to win both sides of the
team were skilled one side had a leader
with willpower his name is Tom Brady
who's won seven championships can you
imagine what he's going through right
now and how he's handling the two
victories he had back to back how do you
do that with the mess marriage personal
life FTX and you've won two games and
you're four and five by your first place
in your you know division because
there's nobody that's good in your
division imagine how much willpower it
takes to be Tom Brady today so this next
one people I I got to figure out a way
how to write a plan I need a right plan
that's great we'll teach you how to
write a plan but what's your mission
what is the mission you give me somebody
on a mission they'll figure out a way to
write the plan out you give me somebody
that's on a serious mission you can't
get in that person's way so instead of
just trying to figure out a way how to
write the right plan what's the mission
systems I need to write systems on how
to process business I need to write
systems on how to sell I need to write
systems how to raise money great no
problem you can find all the systems but
what are your dreams
and I'm talking real dreams I remember
being a guy who was broke forty nine
thousand dollars of debt in my Ford
Focus at 23 years old driving around
given a keynote speech closing speaker
at an event there's nothing about me
that was a closing speaker at an event
at 23 years old but I'm given the speech
and it's like the next person we're
going to bring up is Patrick by David
I'll go
and I would get up hey thank you John
for the warm introduction folks it's
great to be here with you and I was
going to tell my story and I would play
this role of a story I'm telling in my
50s and 60s I was 23 years old I had a
dream
would get me so excited I had a dream
about you know family kids life America
Iran I'm Assyrian I'm Armenia I got a
lot of Dreams your dreams I was in DC
yesterday Washington DC giving a talk to
this group of people in Calverton a
small City with 17 000 people there
there's a few hundred people in this
room and I'm talking to these folks I
said Do You Feel Like Your Dream
Machines kind of been shut off for the
last couple years and then if yes tell
me why
weren't we all dreamers what happened
there you know when somebody's got a
dream and they're chasing it they're
pursuit of their dreams their eyes have
a little twinkle in it you see the fire
if somebody doesn't happen doesn't have
it they just look like it's just life
regular life what are your dreams next
hey I need Capital if I only had a
million dollars I would be able to start
this business if I only had a hundred
thousand dollars if I only had ten
thousand dollars if I only had it's the
if I only had money is not hard to find
a vision is
you give me somebody with a real Vision
they're gonna find the money
you give me somebody with a real Vision
with the right team around them that
people have bought into this Vision
trust me money will show up we had a
real Vision when we started the
insurance company it was very simple
people thought I was crazy but the
vision was real all of a sudden 40 years
later some guy comes and says hey I'll
give you a million dollars cool
four years later another guy came in hey
Oscar De La Hoya Gabriel Brenner these
guys are interested in investing to the
company no problem here's 10 million
dollars 2017.
so I'm going around telling people my
vision and we're growing the company we
got great leaders in the company and
boom well who's this mad guy the Sheena
guy this George guy this Jose guy this
Vargas guy this oh these guys got a real
business these guys got real leaders
this guy's got Tom else this is awesome
this is crazy 10 million hey 35 million
hey few hundred million because there's
a vision Capital showed up even when I
was broke if division was real money
eventually showed up
too many people just want to study their
competition well let me see what the
competition is doing in the real estate
industry yeah you can go get all the
stats you can get all the data but who's
your real enemy
what do you mean by enemy do you have an
enemy Robert Greene was a friend of mine
he uh wrote a book 40 Laws of Power
wrote another book called 33 Strategies
of War
when I first got involved in business I
was very naive I thought everybody
wanted to see me win and I would say
good things otherwise and all of a
sudden I started beating some of the
guys that were telling me I can win and
I noticed some of them turn I'm like
wait what happened here
you were nice now you're talking behind
my back what happened there then I
realized not everybody wants to see you
win okay there's real enemies out there
so for two years you know what's the one
book I read every day and listened to
the audio on Replay for two years 33
Strategies a war because when I started
an insurance company I realized business
is a form of War Sports is a form of War
America right now being number one you
think we have a lot of enemies there's a
form of War China wants to beat us and
be number one this war is not like a
nuclear war we're talking about but
business is war competition is okay
having an enemy produces a different
energy a guy named Michael Jordan knew
how to identify his next enemy you may
need an enemy you're bored out of your
mind right now you don't have an enemy
right now like Pat what's an enemy an
enemy isn't somebody you want to hurt an
enemy could be a father that's no longer
in the picture with you you know I
remember one time reading the story
about Tyler Perry
when Tyler Perry made all the money and
his dad showed up he said man you're so
rich I'm your father I'm this I'm that
he says dad here's what I'm going to do
listen to what Tyler Perry did it's a
very interesting story I don't know if
you know this or not Tyler
Perry
he's got a good name by the way Tyler
Perry
ends up buying his dad a nice car buys
him a house gives him some money with
one caveat never call me ever again I
don't want you in my life
the years I needed you weren't there now
I want you to feel my pain think about
that
you think a part of Tyler Perry Building
the place that he's built and being the
I think he's a billionaire already if
not on his way you think it's just
because he wants to make movies or he
think there's an enemy where his father
wasn't there to support him and tell him
that son I believe in you you think a
Steve Jobs who was given for adoption
doesn't think about the fact that how
dare you give me up for adoption you
think you don't think that's a form of
an enemy what do you have to produce
that kind of fire for you these are the
kind of things that you got to take
inventory of we're going to spend a lot
of time talking about this Supporting
Cast man if I have find a right recruit
the right running mate it's going to be
amazing that's great but what kind of a
culture you got
is your culture the kind of place that
people want to be around do they want to
stay late do they want to go home is it
just like well clock and clock out 459
Club I can't wait to leave boom you're
out of here you're bored out of your
mind well maybe we need a better culture
where you're at so these whole 12
building blocks I can talk about this
for days on top of days because there's
specific strategies on how to do this
here but these are the 12 building
blocks so you heard three different
types of planning financial planning
estate planning business planning due to
popular demand last year a lot of the
businesses like consult said Pat can you
put a course together for business
planning I said no problem we did it
last year a hundred page workbook that
gets sent to everybody that registers
and buys their tickets it's on December
16 this year last year we had people
from 100 plus countries this year will
be the same as well we're expecting a
very big turnout because right now I'm
working on a book with penguin portfolio
where we're talking about how to write a
business plan that's going to come out
next year if you want to join me on this
webinar on December 16 click here get
registered dirt so we can spend a day
together and make 2023 the beginning of
the greatest years of your life go get
registered I'll see you there December
16th
[Music]